what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of Thrones
prediction video today I want to talk
about some of the biggest reunions that
may take place next season the Game of
Thrones television show is almost over
so characters locations and alliances
are starting to change as all the chess
pieces on the board are being shifted to
prepare for the endgame the plot lines
are getting very close to being put in
their final position which means the
characters that are left will either die
or they will have to unite in order to
defeat the night game some of these
characters haven't seen each other in
over years but now that there are only
thirteen episodes left most of the
characters in the show that has been
away from each other for years
we'll start the cross paths once again
some of these reunions will be very
emotional but some of these reunions
could also end up being deadly so let's
go over some of the biggest ones that
are being put in positioned to take
place the character that I want to
discuss is Jon Snow and as we can see in
all the official promos Jon Snow is
going to be on the move next season and
he wound up travelling to multiple
locations which puts him in line with
having several possible reunions this
season within the first few episodes of
season seven we're going to get a pretty
important reunion that has some
significance for the end game Jon Snow
will hold a meeting telling all the
other Lords of the north that he needs
to go south down the Dragonstone so that
he can acquire some dragonglass in order
to fight the white walkers but he will
also go down there to meet Daenerys
Targaryen who currently has one of the
largest armies in the Seven Kingdoms
which is exactly what Jon Snow will need
on his side when it comes time to fight
the night king when Jon arrives on
Dragonstone he will be greeted by our
old friend Tyrion Lannister and I don't
know about everyone else but I am really
looking forward to this reunion I am a
big fan of Jon Snow and Tyrion and I
love their scenes together in season 1
so when they meet again it should be
very interesting to see the interaction
between these two characters so much has
changed since the last time that they
saw each other when they first met Jon
Snow was just another bastard
on his way to spend the rest of his life
at the wall in Tyrion was the despicable
imp
but now they are both in a very powerful
position now that Jon Snow is king in
the north
in carrying his hand of the Queen the
dialogue between these two old friends
should be pretty interesting as we all
know John and Tyrion didn't get along
with each other when they first met but
after spending some time together at the
wall they did begin to respect one
another and I think Tyrion will be the
glue that gets John and Daenerys to
stick together eventually and these
three characters being together is
crucial when it comes time to fight the
night king tyrion has the brains Jon
Snow has the experience and Daenerys has
the firepower this will be one of the
most important meetings of jon snow's
life and I'm really excited for this one
another very important reunion for Jon
Snow next season will be with Samwell
Tarly these two friends parted ways at a
critical moment in the story at the end
of season five Sam left the wall in
order to go to the Citadel to train to
become the next maester for the Nights
Watch and most importantly to figure out
a way to help Jon Snow when the time
comes to fight the night king after Sam
left the wall Jon Snow ended up being
killed by other men of the Nights Watch
obviously John was then resurrected by
Melisandre and he ended up leaving the
Nights Watch and he fought in Ramsay
during the Battle of the bastards and he
now has Winterfell back under the stark
banners so I think it's safe to say that
a lot has happened since these two
characters were last together we are now
getting closer to the point to where
these characters will need to meet again
and devise their plan to overcome this
winter Sam will definitely learn all
that he can during his time at the
Citadel so that he can help John my
guest says Sam will discover some pretty
important information that will help Jon
defeat the night King and he could also
learn about John's true parentage but
whatever the case may be once Sam feels
he has found the information he has been
looking for he will leave the Citadel
and head back up north to meet with John
even though these characters haven't
been away from each other that long this
still has the potential to be a very
emotional reunion considering all that
has happened since then I'm wondering
what Sam's reaction will be when he
learns that Jon Snow was killed by other
men of the Nights Watch that should be
interesting to see but John and Sam
reuniting will also be important to the
end game Sam will also be another
character that makes it until the very
end of this story the infirm
that Sam discovers that the Citadel will
be one of the keys to survival and
without Sam and John reuniting the
people of Westeros probably wouldn't
stand a chance
just like John reuniting with Tyrion
this will also be one of the most
important reunions of John's life but
these aren't the only reunions that will
be important or the key to survival as
we have seen in the trailer bran stark
will make it back to Winterfell not only
is this going to be significant but it's
also going to be very emotional the last
time Jon Snow saw bran
he wasn't even sure if he was ever going
to wake up again but now brain has
learned how to fly and his role for the
end game has become one of the most
crucial roles now that he is the
three-eyed Raven John and Brian were
always very close so I know they're
really looking forward to seeing each
other once again and giving each other a
big hug brain has actually seen John a
few times since then
but every time he saw John they can
never reunite because John was always in
the middle of a damn fight when bran was
traveling to the wall and he hid up in
that Tower
he saw Jon fighting the wildlings that
was when bran worked into his direwolf
to take down some of those wildlings
which ultimately helped John escape then
bran saw Jon again when they were north
of the wall at Craster's keep
bran saw Jon fighting other brothers of
the Nights Watch but he decided not to
stay and instead he headed to the
three-eyed Ravens cave
so when Jon and brand finally get to hug
it out it's going to be very satisfying
to see bran and Jon will also play a
huge role together when they have to
face off against the night king bran
will also play a huge role in telling
Jon about who his true parents are
obviously bran was the one that had the
tower of joy visions and he saw that
Jon's mother is actually Lyanna stark
now Bryan may or may not know who John's
father is yet but that will eventually
be revealed in the show also we all know
who John's father is but Brin did not
see Rhaegar there nor did he hear Liana
say it was Rhaegar son to confirm it but
when brand reveals this information to
Jon it will end up being one of the
biggest moments in the show which I know
most of us have been waiting for and
can't wait to see you have to wonder
though will this information affect Jon
and brands relationship does anyone
think this will change the way bran and
Jon look at each
now that they will know they aren't
actually brothers let me know what you
think about that down below since we're
talking about a stark reunion let's just
move right on to the next one which may
be the most emotional one for some
people which is Jon Snow and Arya Stark
reuniting these two characters also had
a very loving relationship as kids and
they haven't seen each other in years
since then they both more or less have
become two completely different people
in fact when Arya Stark was training
with the faceless men it was the sword
needle that John gave to Arya that she
just wasn't able to get rid of to
completely become no one she was not
able to let go of that part of her life
the thought alone brought her to tears
Arya Stark has already made it back to
Westeros and she is crossing names off
her list as she makes her way up north
to Winterfell so it's just a matter of
time before she makes it back home but
when she does Jon might not even be
there I have a feeling Jon's going to be
gone when Arya arrives he's either going
to be down in Dragonstone or he's going
to be up north of the wall but I'm
holding out hope that we will see this
happen before the end of the season I'm
really curious to see how Jon reacts to
what Arya has become I would love to get
a scene of all the stark children
sitting down together telling each other
everything that they have been through
another big reunion that we can see next
season maybe between Jon Snow and
Melisandre in the first season 7 trailer
we could see Melisandre standing on the
hill at Dragonstone and she was
overlooking a group of people walking up
to the castle this may be Melisandre
watching as Jon Snow and Davos arrive
the last time we saw Melisandre was in
the season 6 finale after Jon Snow
exiled her from the north after he
learned that she sacrificed princess
Shireen when Jon Snow told Melisandre to
leave the north or else she would be
executed she gave Jon Snow one last
piece of advice that could end up
playing a role still German isn't safe
yourself
I've been ready to die for many years if
the Lord was done with me so beautifully
you've seen the night kingdom snow you
know the Great War still to come you
know the army of the Dead will be upon
us soon
and you know I can help you win their
war you have to wonder what exactly
Melisandre meant by this we know she can
resurrect John and make shadow babies
but did she mean something else did she
have some other magical powers up her
sleeve that we have yet to see I wonder
what other kind of crazy [ __ ] she can do
to help against the night King I am very
curious to see how things go down when
Jon Snow and Davos get the dragon stone
and they see that Melisandre is there
there is one more reunion I want to
discuss but this will be a two for one
John and his group of companions will go
far north beyond the wall and at some
point during this mission they will
become under attack we have seen plenty
of evidence of this in the trailer Jon
Snow and his team are going to be
surrounded by what looks like thousands
of lights and there also be White
Walkers there but most important of all
the night King will be here too the last
time Jon Snow is this far north of the
wall he was introduced to the night King
and I must say it was one hell of an
introduction this scene shocked fans
across the globe book readers and show
Watchers Jon Snow and the night King had
one of the most epic stare downs of all
time we all knew that this scene would
have a payoff at some point well this
season we can get our first taste of
that payoff when Jon Snow and the night
King meet again we saw how much interest
the night king took in Jon when he
witnessed Jon defeat one of the White
Walkers so it's going to be very
exciting and interesting when the night
King sees Jon again this is another
reaction I am very curious about from
what we've seen in the trailer it
appears like Jon Snow's going to end up
all alone as White's are all around him
and I know some people think this is
benjin standing here but that is Jon
Snow you can see that he has his hair up
in a bun and you can see that he has
long claw in his hand
plus he has the
dagger tucked down the back of his belt
but at the end of the trailer we can
also see Jon Snow riding off on a black
horse and you can see that John has that
dagger tucked down the back of his belt
here too but somehow John is going to be
able to escape the knight Kings grasp
once again and there is probably only
one way John is going to be able to
escape what's most of you already know
when brain and mirror was in trouble who
showed up just in time to save them the
same person that's going to show up just
in time to save John which is Uncle
Benjen
aka uncle cold hands benjin went ranging
beyond the wall and he disappeared for
years and ever since then John has been
wondering where the hell he has been and
if he would ever see him again although
they didn't spend a lot of time together
they did have a strong bond and it may
be that bond that ultimately saves
John's life when he gets attacked by the
night king and his army I know some
people commented on my trailer breakdown
video and said that this black horse
could be anybody's black horse which is
true but come on
that is definitely benjin's horse that
john is riding on at the end what's
interesting is when Jon Snow was killed
it was that little [ __ ] ollie that
tricked him into coming outside because
he told John that someone knew where his
uncle Benjen was but now it will be his
uncle Benjen who saves his life that's
going to be pretty damn poetic in a
sense if you ask me but as you can see
Jon Snow is going to be very busy next
season traveling all across Westeros and
coming into contact with some old
friends some old enemies and family
members that he truly loves all of these
reunions are very important to John's
story moving forward and ultimately the
end game of Game of Thrones which one
are you most excited for or is there
another reunion you really want to see
that involves two completely different
characters comment down below and let me
know what you think as always thank you
all so much for stopping by and
supporting the channel in this video
also a special thank you to all my
patreon supporters the love you all show
means a lot to me and for that I love
you all I'll see you down below bye